all the vector listen for that straight
so here and come up inside his circle
feet together
Turner scroll minute oh I'm in - come on
here okay so right from here it doesn't
take much fiddle that full boom
Giovanni weapon out of the centerline
Dominic descending on so vector I want
to hear the scrape and is sticking it
stick inside
I
sit sit sit sit
stick stick stick she's gonna give me
the top go down flap your dish at the
top
[Applause]
let's go so my manoeuvre is as I over
penetrated due to his IP geometry when
he comes around the fight with routine
so that I don't get fun
do you understand okay so I'm forget
what happened with the joke you keep
your job doing step alright so as I move
around
now I will not draw the showman back
because of you can mean anything which
is you tell me that you're taking the
whole time you guys think you can me is
the second absorption or a harder
version if that is part of it but the
heart of it is he he throws the strike
right this is not IP that was movement
ideas boom right in that relaxation
that's not that's not it I believe the
tension he can't expand hands and that's
where the stickiness comes from okay
this looks different
no you see there's a there's a
stickiness there's a stickiness when I
hit it
I'm not hitting it I'm sticking on it
but he has to stick to me because he's
learning before so
[Music]
by relapse you go go like that not like
this
stick your knives then if you would
tries to choke boom take cameras brother
Joe do anything you did that same thing
here this relaxation absorption it's
like a micro absorption if I go yet
no matter what he's doing right
I will we
[Music]
once you feel that
there's no change
so what we saw a lot was trying to see
how I created the distance do you see
the distance between I gave you that
[Music]
[Applause]
see
No where did I explain this is
unfortunate to reoxidation that causes
the adhesion if I don't have that I want
pops there and he will displace my
weapon okay what happened it's still
there
he's skis
I stay young on his John he will
displace me but if as I go that door we
will stick you see we stick keep down
trust so once you see your target on
absorb absorb Jenna and the weapons will
not be displaced it sticks that's why I
was trying to show you on the bodyguard
portion its sticks there and then he
can't read the draw get it they said
give up the center understand but if you
don't stick it don't matter what he does
you gave up the center line he do
whatever okay so
right so I'm here that's just Russell
isn't it did you see my grip it was open
wasn't it so if I destroys your weapon
and I'm here then I'm gonna get in do
you get it but I can withdraw I see
[Music]
I don't need to let go I'm just showing
you this mothers in absorbs it in tears
okay try I need to have that's a
community okay the seed of IP is
invisible and eternal nice okay in this
last move I only have to see an internal
releasing and absorption there is no
external absorption
what's an external source and its dermal
absorption is well so you're gonna see
my body absorb sound so he goes and we
watch my body you see that so you guys
all have an external absorption but
inside that he's supposed to get
internal absorption enemies it's the
seed which is why when you to mock me up
toast you tell me don't really do it
okay so I come around if there's an
insert in turtle it's as much
psychological as it is physiological so
it's not that I moved my body he said I
release the tension in my tissues I
release he goes all he has is up and
it's terminal of release and absorption
because there is no real anatomical
external absorption his job will get
this place every time I will quit his
house every time okay
he just has to have a release if our
weapons will stick okay forcing me to go
from there to here which gives him the
opening because if he gives me the
distance no I hit it over here dead like
a whole lot of weapon out you understand
you see Dave he goes can't ever hit it
because I I got stuff